stéphane augé chef du service de
réanimation pédiatrique à l'hôpital
robert debré à paris stéphane augé merci
d'être avec nous bienvenue sur rt france
alors vous êtes un des premiers à avoir
lancé la grève du codage c'est quoi
exactement est qu'elle en était à
l'époque l'utilité bonjour madame merci
beaucoup c'est une rétention des
financements généré par chaque
hospitalisation de malades
c'est à dire qu'on continue et qu'on
continue et qu'on continue à soigner
comme d'habitude mais par contre qu'on
ne fait pas remonter à la sécurité
sociale des prestations le coût de
chaque hospitalisation ça a posé des
difficultés finalement l'administration
qui s'est rendu compte du mal-être et
c'était notre objectif de bien ressentir
et faire ressentir que ce n'était plus
un problème de financement en permanence
mais un problème de qualité des soins
qu'ils étaient maintenant à l'hôpital
public et qu'il fallait vraiment réagir
rapidement
on a obtenu au moins quelques
discussions mais pour l'instant aucune
avancée donc il est temps qu'on passe à
autre chose
alors vous dites aucune avancée un plan
d'urgence a pourtant été promises par
l'exécutif c'est pas suffisant pour vous
c'est loin d'être suffisant
ah oui madame très clairement c'est loin
d'être suffisant comme nous le disons
depuis plusieurs mois ce sont
différentes institutions dont la cour
des comptes qui ont très bien expliqué
que l'augmentation de l'ondam du
financement de l'hospitalisation n'est
pas du tout à la hauteur des charges de
l'hôpital aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas
capables de continuer à produire des
soins de qualité
et quand notre nouveau ministre
s'inquiète à juste titre du coronavirus
comme on l'a souvent dit mme typiquement
moi je suis pédiatre et je suis beaucoup
moins touché pour l'instant puisque les
enfants ont l'air d'être moins touchées
il est très clair que nous ne serions
pas prêt à recevoir une épidémie
respiratoires de grande amplitude en
pédiatrie en ile de france
si nous n'avons pas plus rapidement des
ouvertures de lits des revalorisations
des salaires qui permettent au personnel
de rester chez nous et d'être motivé
actuellement dans le service dont
j'étais responsable puisque j'ai
démissionné de mes fonctions de chef de
service
il y à une grève depuis 80 jours et mes
collègues ne sont toujours pas entendues
ce qu'elle réclame c'est juste quatre 4
jours de congés supplémentaires dans
l'année pour récupérer dès 13h ou dès
13h30 qu'elles sont à chaque fois
qu'elles viennent travailler dans le
service
nous nous sommes pas entendus le
financement n'est pas à la hauteur de ce
que nous avons demandé c'est la cour des
comptes qu'il dit il est temps que ce
nouveau ministre qui dit très très bien
connaître les dossiers nous montre tout
de suite dès les jours qui viennent sa
volonté d'avancer alors à quel point le
manque de moyens que vous déplorez
retenti sur les patients alors ça
retenti dans les services d'urgences
vous le savez depuis plus d'un an le
collègue sont mobilisés d'urgence ça
ressenti sur toute la chaîne des soins
par exemple en réanimation pédiatrique
il faut prendre tout de suite des
patients qui sont dans des urgences
vitales et être capable pour cela de
libérer des lits c'est à dire de faire
sortir des patients pour en prendre de
nouveau et là c'est quelque chose de
totalement impossible si nous n'avons
pas les moyens d'ouvrir d'ouvrir des
lits dans tous les secteurs d'aval des
soins aigus s'est réclamée par le comité
interroge le collectif inter hospitalier
depuis plusieurs mois déjà et
aujourd'hui nous n'avons
pour bien vu venir alors très rapidement
peut-être une réaction après la
démission d'agnès busan alors une
réaction madame je ne rentre pas dans
les histoires politiques ce qui est sûr
c'est que notre nouveau mise de la santé
l'a dit à l'assemblée nationale le dit
et on le sait est très très motivés et
connaît très bien les dossiers sur
lequel nous voulons avancer
nous n'allons nous n'attendons que des
gestes forts mais tout de suite
l'hôpital public est en danger imminent
c'est tout de suite qu'il faut nous
donner les moyens de travailler
correctement
donc dès qu'il nous proposera un rendez
vous avec d'emblée des gestes forts sur
la revalorisation des salaires sur la
réouverture des lignes sur leur
financement pour ne pas mettre dès le
mois prochain
les hôpitaux publics de nouveau en
endettement eh bien nous nous remettrons
au travail avec lui pour avancer et il
n'est pas nécessaire de refaire encore
une fois des plans pour comprendre
quelle est la situation de l'hôpital
public mais se verront le sait très bien
il est neurologue il est médecin il y à
travailler il connaît les dossiers
donc il faut qu'on avance très
clairement tout de suite ses fans dauger
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
le rappelle vous êtes chef du service de
réanimation pédiatrique à l'hôpital
parisien robert debré merci